[Music]
Tori Spelling and Dean McDermott have
started counseling again we've
definitely kind of had to not start over
but rebirth the relationship as
something that was new and kind of
moving on towards the future a source
tells ET the two are dedicated to
improving their marriage adding quote
they realize things got completely out
of hand when their blowout fights became
very public as painful as that period
has been in their life it was also very
eye-opening for them our source adds the
stress stemmed from money issues which
they are now working closely with an
accountant to fix this isn't the first
we've heard about the ups and downs of
Tori and Dean the two even opened up to
ET about how their relationship has
changed throughout their decade of
marriage you know I was just thinking
about it in the car ride over here I was
just thinking how grateful I am and how
fulfilled with gratitude I am that we're
still together and my life is wonderful
I have these wonderful babies with you I
have this wonderful life with you and I
was just thinking about that away over
I'm just I'm so grateful and happy
definitely defied what society has told
us you know a relationship should be
monogamy should be this is what happens
when indiscretion happens and it can't
go forward and you know we've kind of
thrown all that out the window and just
focused on each other and what's grown
is something that it's been even more
amazing than either of us thought could
ever be
you